- Yes, yes, yes!
- Ça déménage dans la famille
Laurent! Un nouvel appartement
est plus petit, mais il leur
permettra d'économiser 350 $
par mois.
- On se tasse un peu plus,
on est un peu plus à l'étroit,
mais au moins on économise...
on éconooup.
- Jusqu'à la veille
du déménagement, Francine
n'avait toujours pas de camion
en raison des prix de location
au-dessus de ses moyens.
Laura Blondiaux, elle,
s'y est pris d'avance.
- On a dû s'y prendre 3-4 mois
avant et on a eu la dernière
place, donc la place du soir,
e personne ne veut.
Donc, ça, c'est pas trop cool.
- Et là encore, elle croise
les doigts pour que
ses déménageurs, trouvés
sur la Facebook, ne lui fassent
pas faux bond. C'est d'ailleurs
une situation qui est de plus en
plus fréquente, note Pierre-
Olivier Cyr du Clan Panneton.
PIERRE-OLIVIER CYR, propriétaire
Le Clan Panneton
- Mais, énormément d'entreprises
peu fiables vont décider plutôt
de lâcher les clients qu'ils
ont reservés au moins
de janvier-février pour prendre
des clients de dernière minute
qui eux sont dans une situation
de détresse et qui sont prêts
à payer plus cher.
C'est-tu un autre
qui se fait évincer?
- Oui, c'est le propriétaire
qui paye.
- Il note aussi que 60 % de
ses rendez-vous de déménagement
sont liés à des rénovictions.
Les taux d'inoccupation
des logements dans les grand
villes du Québec se situent
en dessous des 5 %.
Montréal arrive en tête
avec 3,6 % de logements
inoccupés contre une saturation
remarquée dans des villes comme
Trois-Rivières et Rimouski.
- Aujourd'hui, toutes
les offices d'habitation,
toutes les ressources sont
en poste. C'est important,
il faut demander de l'aide.
Et également, on a donné
également des montants
aux municipalités pour
entreposer, déménager, donc
offrir de l'aide également
à tous ceux qui en ont besoin.
- 750 ménages n'avaient toujours
pas trouvé de logement
à la vielle du 1er juillet
au Québec.
Ici Danielle Kadjo,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.